Prof: Anyhow,
so today I'm going to try and
wrap up a few loose ends.
So I'm going to try and talk
about the high water mark of
finance which is basically CAPM
and Black-Scholes,
both of which we've almost
talked about,
almost finished talking about,
and I'm going to talk in the
middle about Social Security
which we never finished,
my Social Security plan.
So I hope to deal with all
three of these things today.
So just to wrap up the CAPM,
the CAPM had two main ideas.
The first idea was
diversification and the second
main idea, as we said,
was the tradeoff between risk
and return.
Shakespeare had both of these
ideas.
He understood that you're safer
if you've got each of your boats
on a different ocean,
and he understood that if
you're going to take a high risk
you'd better get a high return
otherwise nobody is willing to
take it.
And so he made that very clear.
In fact I think the whole point
of the play is about economics,
The Merchant of Venice,
and he made both of these
principles very clear,
but he couldn't quantify them
and he couldn't mathematize
them,
and the Capital Asset Pricing
Model gives a mathematical,
quantifiable form to both and a
quite shocking recommendation in
both cases.
So just to draw those two
pictures,
for those of you who didn't
hear it last night,
if you do Tobin's famous
picture, this is the
Markowitz-Tobin Capital Market
Line they called it.
It's very important to keep
straight what's on the diagram.
There's the standard deviation
of any asset per dollar.
So here I'm writing the price.
So it's per dollar,
and here is the expectation of
the asset per dollar.
So pi of Y, I'm calling that
the price.
So this is per dollar.
And I'm not going to go over
what we derived before,
but we noticed that if you took
all the risky assets,
any risky asset's going to have
per dollar,
if it's priced,
some standard deviation and
some expectation.
You can write down all the
risky assets,
and you can combine them,
and you'll get a possibility
set that looks like this.
So the diversification already
shows up in this picture because
if you combine this asset and
this asset you're going to get
possibilities by putting half of
your money in each,
not on the straight line
between them,
but on some curved line that's
much better because you're
reducing your risk.
So Markowitz already had that
curve and this picture in mind.
Tobin added the riskless asset,
which he put here,
and then he said,
well, if there's a riskless
asset everybody's going to do
the same thing and everyone's
going to choose the same point.
It's better for everybody,
so this is the optimal risky
portfolio and it has to be equal
to the market,
because if everybody's smart
enough to figure out what to do
they're all going to do the same
thing,
and whatever everybody holds
that's by definition the market.
So Tobin showed that everybody
should choose something on this
capital market line and so
everybody should split his money
between the market and a
riskless asset.
Put your money in the bank or
own the entire market.
That was his recommendation and
that was the beginning of the
whole idea of index investing.
So that was the first idea,
first, most important idea.
Now, how could you test this?
Well, you could simply test
every fund in history and
compare so called experts and
see if those guys could get you
above this line.
So by the way,
the slope of the line,
one more thing,
is the slope equals Sharpe
ratio.
So everybody's trying to get
the highest Sharpe ratio they
can,
and if you have this portfolio
you've made a mistake,
you haven't held the optimal
one, then the slope of your
performance will be a lower
Sharpe ratio than that.
The slope of this,
which is the Sharpe ratio of
that point, is worse than the
slope of that,
which is the Sharpe ratio of
this point.
And the Sharpe ratio,
remember, is (the expectation
per dollar minus what you can
get in the riskless asset per
dollar) divided by the started
deviation of Y per dollar,
let's say.
So that's just the slope of
this line.
So we can measure performance
of a portfolio manger by the
Sharpe ratio.
Everyone should try and get the
highest Sharpe ratio.
The upshot of diversification
is you should buy a little bit
of every stock in the economy no
matter how small,
no matter how big,
no matter how safe,
no matter how risky,
you should spread your money
across everything.
That's the recommendation of
Tobin.
And it relies,
of course, on everybody else
being rational,
so everybody else is choosing
the right thing.
Then you can just piggyback and
do what everybody else is doing.
So that's the first thing.
Very shocking,
as I said, at first glance
you'd think someone who loves
risk would just invest in risky
stocks and people who are very
risk averse would just invest in
safe stocks.
Tobin says, no, no, no, no.
If you're risk averse you
should just put most of your
money in the bank and hold a
little bit of every stock.
So you're here somewhere.
If you're very risk tolerant
you shouldn't just concentrate
on the risky stocks.
You should buy the same
proportion of all stocks as
everyone else,
but you should borrow the money
to do it and maybe way up here.
And people who borrow money to
invest that's called leveraging.
So that's idea number one,
the crucial idea.
There are a lot of ideas mixed
in that,
and as I said,
you can test it by seeing if
anyone can beat the market--
is there anyone historically
that has had a higher Sharpe
ratio than the market.
In 1967 when all of this was
being tested there was a famous
book called A Random Walk Down
Wall Street written by Malkiel,
which I recommend you read.
He gives the history of tests
of whether people could beat the
market.
Of course many people beat the
market for short periods of
time.
Then they totally collapse.
And then some people beat the
market for 20 years in a row and
then retire,
but there are so few of those
people that it looks like just
by random dumb luck you could
get almost those people.
On the other hand there are
some people like Warren Buffet
who seem to beat the market for
40 or 50 years.
It's really hard to believe
that that's all just luck.
And so that's one test of the
thing.
The second idea of the Capital
Asset Pricing Model is risk and
return.
And so now if we assume--so all
this graph,
by the way, assumed quadratic
utilities,
quadratic or mean variance
quadratic utility and common
probabilities.
So everybody knew what the
probabilities were of the
different states,
so you know how to measure the
covariance and the variance and
all that because you know what
the probabilities are to measure
over.
So here, having assumed that,
it turns out that you just
apply the principle that we saw
the first few days of class,
that the price is going to
equal the marginal utility,
not the total utility.
Price is going to equal
marginal utility and if the
price equals the marginal
utility the marginal utility is
going to be--
depends, according to this
assumption of quadratic
utilities as we showed,
depends on expectation.
So this is the price of Y,
so let's just call it pi of Y
like I did before.
It depends on the expectation
of Y and it depends on the
covariance of Y with the market.
We've assumed with quadratic
utilities that people only care
about the mean and the variance,
so you'd have expected the
marginal utility of any single
asset to depend on its mean and
its variance,
but it's the marginal utility.
It's what it adds to what
you've already got.
So it adds expectation because
expectation's additive,
but when you add another stock
to what you already have,
the variance of the whole
portfolio changes according to
the covariance of the new thing
with what you already had,
and everybody already had the
market.
So given that you know that the
price,
mathematically therefore,
the price has to equal
something times the expectation
of Y plus something times the
covariance of Y with the market.
But that's true for all Y.
In particular it's true for the
riskless asset.
So the riskless asset pays 1
for sure, has no covariance with
anything like the market,
and its price is 1 over (1 r).
So therefore A has to be 1 over
(1 r).
So we know that this has to be
And then B could be whatever it
is.
The covariance,
by the way, is going to be bad,
so this is minus.
And then B, you have to figure
B out.
So you don't know what B is a
priori.
You don't know what the
interest rate is either.
You had to see that in the
market.
Once you know the price of one
asset,
and you know its correlation
with the market,
if you knew this price,
and you know the expectation of
Y,
and you know the covariance
with the market that will tell
you B.
So once you've given one price
of a risky asset,
like of the market as a whole,
you're going to be able to
figure out the price of every
other asset because from that
one price you can deduce B,
and once you have B you can
price everything.
So that's the second idea,
risk and return.
And you can see it graphically
and more dramatically,
because if I take that same
equation,
this is called the covariance
pricing formula,
you take that and divide by pi
of Y you get 1 equals
expectation of Y divided by the
price of Y--
dividing both sides by pi of
Y-- minus B times the covariance
of (Y over the price of Y) with
M.
So that just tells me the
expectation and the covariance
of a dollar's worth,
just like this was a dollar's
worth.
This was per dollar and this is
per dollar,
so if you put the covariance of
Y and the pi of Y down here,
and M over here,
and here you put expectation Y
over pi of Y,
this just says this is just a
constant,
and this is a constant,
so it says this and this are
linearly related.
These are all securities who
have price 1.
There has to be a linear
relationship between their
expectation per dollar and their
covariance per dollar with the
market.
And as the covariance gets
higher the return gets higher.
So if you take a stock with a
high covariance it's going to
have to have a high expected
return.
That's exactly what Shakespeare
said.
If it's more risky people won't
hold it unless it's got a higher
return, which means you can buy
it for a cheap price.
So its price is less than its
expectation.
But the difference with
Shakespeare is we've quantified
risk.
It's not what you would have
thought, variance,
it's covariance.
And that's it.
Those are the two big ideas and
you could test--
so this is called the Security
Market Line,
and you could test this by
asking is every stock--
so if you look at every stock
last year,
you look at its covariance,
you put a point here,
then you look this year at its
expected return,
of course some stocks are going
to be wild,
but you average over a bunch of
stock and a bunch of years.
Do you get things that lie in a
straight line or close to a
straight line?
And Sharpe, in 1967,
found that amazingly when you
did that you got--so I described
last night exactly what his test
was.
You got something that looked
incredibly close to a straight
line like that.
So this was the greatest
triumph in the history of the
social sciences,
it was called,
because you had huge amounts of
data,
huge capacity to test things,
a shocking conclusion,
a shockingly precise theory to
test,
and it fit the line so
incredibly closely.
And it just swept,
it made a huge impression in
finance and in economics and
lots of Nobel Prizes were given
for this.
Sharpe won a Nobel Prize.
Markowitz won a Nobel Prize.
Tobin won a Nobel Prize.
Lintner died.
He would have won a Nobel Prize
too.
So this was the first major
triumph, the most important
triumph of finance,
the Capital Asset Pricing
Model.
Now, as it happens,
as the theory's been tested
over and over again every year
since 1967 it's performed more
and more poorly.
And so now when you do this you
get points that look like this,
and like that,
and like this,
and they don't seem to lie on a
straight line at all,
and it's pretty shocking how up
until '67 or the early '70s that
it seemed to work out perfectly
and now it doesn't work very
well.
And this business they've also
discovered, according to this
you couldn't beat the market.
So how do you test whether
something beats the market?
You can pick a bunch of people
and say,
"Could they beat the
market,"
or you can actually just make
up a strategy yourself like buy
only new stocks.
Just every year buy the stocks
that have come onto the S&P
500 for the first time,
or just buy the stocks that are
the biggest 10 percent.
And it turns out some of those
strategies actually do beat the
market.
So I don't have time to go into
the details, you know,
that is they lie above or below
here.
So the theory has come into--so
theory and doubt.
And so what I'm going to talk
about next week is,
and it certainly doesn't
explain the current crisis,
so I want next week to explain
crisis.
So next week I'm going to end
by giving another theory which
is going to explain the crisis
and be different from this one,
but of course it hasn't been
tested over 30 years or 50 years
like CAPM.
CAPM looked great for the first
20 years,
so whatever I say next week
will probably turn out to be 90
percent wrong,
but at the moment it looks
pretty good.
And I didn't want to spend half
the course on it in case in 20
years it seemed to be
ridiculous.
But anyway, I'm going to
present it anyway to those of
you who want to hear it next
week,
and it'll be,
I think, understandable and
down to earth and it'll invoke a
very basic thing.
Nowhere in this model did we
take into account,
you know, when we say people
leverage that means they're
borrowing money and choosing to
go up here.
We haven't taken into account
that they have to pay the money
back, and who's going to trust
them to pay the money back?
And forcing them to do
something to guarantee they're
going to pay the money back is
going to change the theory in a
critical way,
which I'll get to next week.
Now, one last thing about the
theory,
as I say, you test it by
seeing--nobody should be above
this line and nobody should be
above this line,
but of course you can find
people above this line.
Swensen, to take a famous Yale
example, is above this line.
And you can find people above
this line, Ellington.
So Ellington,
let's say, above this line.
All right, so hedge funds.
Let's call it an anonymous
hedge fund since we're on camera
now, hedge fund,
hedge fund E.
So the question is,
is that luck,
they just did it a few years in
both cases like 15 years apiece,
or does it mean something?
All right, well,
so you can measure the,
you know, if you believe this
theory and you just say,
okay, let's say the theory's 99
percent true,
it's just that there are a few
people who really do beat the
market,
then you can decide by looking
at these graphs just how good is
Swensen relative to the market?
How good is this hedge fund
relative to the market?
And so you have a way of
calibrating and measuring how
well people do.
So I don't have time to get
into that, but I would measure
the quality of a hedge fund by
its marginal Sharpe ratio.
How much does having access to
this hedge fund,
if you added it to your
portfolio, increase your
portfolio hedge ratio
[correction: Sharpe ratio]?
That's, I think,
the right measure of how good a
hedge fund is.
And the right measure of how
good Swensen is,
is, what's his Sharpe ratio?
And so there's a different
criterion.
I keep emphasizing this.
Swensen is managing an entire
portfolio so you have to measure
him on how's he done for Yale,
because Yale's not going to
combine him with something else.
It's just holding what he holds.
So it's his Sharpe ratio.
But Ellington,
you're going to combine
Ellington with some other stuff.
So Swensen might invest in
Ellington, but ten million other
things.
And so you have to say how much
is Ellington going to help
Swensen's Sharpe ratio?
So instead of Swensen's Sharpe
ratio how much is Ellington
going to help the market Sharpe
ratio?
So that's how you should
measure a hedge fund,
its marginal Sharpe ratio,
and Swensen by his Sharpe
ratio.
So I'd say measure Swensen
performance by Sharpe ratio,
measure hedge fund performance
by marginal Sharpe ratio,
because you'd be crazy to put
all your money in a hedge fund.
The only people who do it are
the partners of the hedge fund
who are sort of forced to do it
because that's how they can
persuade investors that they're
really paying attention to their
fund,
because all their money's at
risk.
So that's it.
That's the basic bottom line.
So are there any questions
before I now move on from this?
We talked about this last night
and we talked about it for the
last two lectures.
All right, so it's a high water
mark as I say;
incredibly precise prediction
and incredibly close to the
facts, at least in 1967 but not
after that.
Now, I want to move to an aside
of Social Security before I come
back to Black-Scholes which is
the last high water mark of the
standard theory.
Remember the upshot of what
we've talked about so far.
The upshot of this is that the
market will get a higher return.
Oh, by the way,
I'd say one other thing.
What is the standard critique
of this theory?
So of course everybody else has
seen that the theory doesn't
work.
So what is their explanation
for why?
What's the old explanation for
why the theory isn't working so
well now?
The explanation is that in the
old days what was thought of as
the market was just all American
stocks.
But now it's pretty obvious,
in fact it should have been
obvious from the beginning.
And so Swensen realized it
early on that Markowitz's advice
is to diversify,
diversify, diversify,
not just into all American
stocks,
into everything all over the
world and all kinds of assets
that aren't stocks at all.
So what you measure as the
market shouldn't just be
American stocks.
It should be the world
portfolio, but how do you
measure the world portfolio?
That's hard to do,
and so people have tried to
maintain that the reason the
theory doesn't work is because
we've got the wrong M in all
these equations.
So that would be a nice way of
fixing the theory.
I doubt if that's going to help
in the end.
So my problem about collateral
is a different look at it.
But anyhow, so the market
according to the theory will get
a higher return than bonds,
and of course that's true.
The market has a very high
positive covariance with itself
so a very low price up here.
It's high covariance with
itself, so a low price.
Compared to its expectation the
price is low,
so you're paying much less than
the expectation.
So then when you see what
actually happens it's going to
look much higher than that.
It's not just this.
The price is lower therefore
the final outcome's going to be
much bigger on average.
So to put it another way,
if you had two possibilities
which you knew were equally
likely,
1 half and 1 half,
and the market paid off
something good here and
something bad here,
so everybody's rich here and
everybody's poor here.
The price of the Arrow security
of this state is going to be
much lower than the price of the
Arrow security of this state.
So this state is going to have
a price,
let's say .8,
and this one might have a price
.2 because here the bad state,
that's when everybody's poor,
so you're going to,
you know, this formula
basically tells you that if
you're paying off here you're
negatively correlated with the
market,
you're going to have to pay a
very high price for it because
you're hedging.
By buying this security you're
balancing off what you have with
the market.
By buying the market,
people don't like that because
it adds more risk to what you
already have.
And so people don't like it so
they're not going pay very much,
so the price will be much less
than the actual probability of 1
half.
So that's the conclusion of
what we've done.
I want to now connect this to
Social Security.
So you remember in our Social
Security model we had land that
went here,
here, here, paid 1,1,
1,1, 1, and we had these
people,
overlapping generations-people
like that.
And we discovered a very
important thing.
The reason why Social Security
seems to be broke is because we
gave away so much money to the
people in the first generation.
It's not that Social Security
wastes money like George Bush
seems to imply whenever he talks
about it.
It's not like they just throw
it away.
It's that we gave a huge gift
to the people in the '40s,
the '50s and the '60s and so
everyone after that has to pay
for that gift.
But there's a little bit more
to George Bush's story than I've
allowed so far,
which is that he wants to put
the money into stocks.
And we know that stocks are
going to get a higher return
than bonds.
That's the whole point of this
theory.
You put money in stocks,
the expected return on stocks
is higher than the expected
return on bonds.
So if you want to make this
mathematical we have to add the
possibility of risk and stocks
and it looks like it's going to
be hopelessly complicated,
but we can do it very easily.
So I'm going to reproduce the
same picture with uncertainty in
stocks in it,
and then we're going to come
back to Social Security and
spend 15 minutes talking about
what's the right plan for Social
Security.
So how could I take this simple
model,
which already seemed
complicated, it's already a
pretty complicated model,
had no uncertainty,
and now put uncertainty in it?
Well, I'm going to suppose that
land--so this is the land
dividends I'm now going to
describe.
And by the way,
I had people with endowments
here.
They were (3,1) and (3,1).
Remember, this is their
endowments, but we didn't say
where those endowments came
from.
So I'm going to take the land
dividends.
I'm going to suppose the
dividend of the land today is 1,
but things might get better or
worse in the future.
Maybe the dividend goes to 2 or
down to 1 half,
say.
I'm taking some extreme case
where it doubles or halves,
and maybe after that it could
double again or it could go back
to 1 and here it could go to 1
or it could go to 1 quarter.
So what dividends are doing is
a random walk.
If the economy starts getting
more productive then it's in a
better position,
and from that point things get
even more productive or maybe go
back to where they were.
If things get worse they're
worse, but maybe things will
start to get better again or
continue to get worse.
So this is what I imagine as my
process of dividends.
So if you own the land you get
all these dividends in the whole
infinite future,
all right?
And now let's say that there's
labor as well,
so labor income.
So I have to make an assumption
about labor income.
So I'm going to assume only
young work.
So here we kind of made the
same assumption.
You get a lot when you're young
and not much when you're old.
I'm going to assume only the
young work,
and I'm going to assume that
this productivity gains or
losses,
and by the way,
you might think you never go
backwards.
Maybe it goes from 1 to 2 or 1
to 1.1.
So it's always growing,
but random.
But I'm just going to keep it
here since I solved this example
last night.
I might as well stick to that
one, but there's no reason
why--I could have made the thing
always, no matter what,
either stay the same or get
better.
That might have been a better
example to do,
more realistic because we don't
really have tremendous
productivity declines,
but anyway, all I mean to do is
to put some randomness here.
So only young work and wages
proportional to dividends,
so let's just assume this,
so I'm assuming--this is what's
called neutral technical change.
So presumably the reason why
productivity is going up,
the dividends are getting
higher, is there are more
discoveries improving the
product of the land,
but they're probably also
improving the product of labor,
and so let's say they have same
effect on both.
So I'm going to assume that
labor is actually--put the 1
above.
Let's say labor always gets 3
times what dividends are.
So this is a 6 and this will be
3 halves, and this will be 12
and 3 again and 3 quarters,
so that's what labor is
getting, so labor income.
I shouldn't have switched
colors, labor income.
So that's my complicated world,
way more complicated than it
was before.
So if you own the land you get
all the dividends in the future.
People live two periods,
so I'm going to assume that
utility--
so you're going to live when
you're young and then when
you're old and up and when
you're old and down.
So you're going to live--let's
say a guy born here,
he's young here,
or she's young here.
She can work here,
and then she's going to be old
here and here,
but when she's old it's not
clear how good her investment's
going to turn out.
So this is going to just be our
simple log.
I'll call this 1 half log Y 1
quarter log Z_up 1
quarter log Z_down.
So you don't discount the
future, let's say,
you just take log of
consumption today plus
probability 1 half of log
consumption in the up state,
1 half log consumption in the
down state.
So the probabilities here are 1
half.
These are the objective
probabilities.
So maybe I should have written
the utility--maybe better it
would have been to write the
utility like that.
That's what people know,
what the probabilities are.
So that's it.
That's my set up.
So what should the economy do?
What should people do?
You see, if you buy--if you're
some person like this woman
here,
she could decide to hold bonds,
and she could get whatever the
interest rate turns out to be,
which we're going to compute in
a minute,
or she could hold stock in
which case she's going to get--
let's start her off here, maybe.
She could buy land;
buy stock.
Now we don't know what the
price is yet.
We have to compute that.
But if she buys the stock
she'll get a dividend of 2 here
and be able to sell the land for
a high price,
because from here on it's
obviously pretty productive,
better than it was back here,
or she might get unlucky and
the price might,
you know, the dividend might be
really terrible,
just 1 half,
and not only that but the land
she sells when she's old is also
going to have a really lousy
price.
So if she holds land she's
going to get a high dividend and
a high capital return,
or else a low dividend and a
low capital return.
It's really risky for her,
or she could just buy a bond at
whatever interest rate it turns
out to be and get something
safe.
So what should she do,
and will that be a good thing
for the economy or can we make
everybody better off by using
Social Security?
So how can we solve this?
So it looks like a really
complicated model to solve
because we've got a generation
born here,
another one born here,
the same generation might be
born up here under different
circumstances,
and then this generation here
could be born under any of three
different circumstances,
so there's a lot to solve for.
But what we know is that when
we compute the Arrow price,
starting from any point,
this Arrow price is going to be
bigger than 1 half and this
one's going to be less than 1
half because the economy is
doing much worse down here so
people know they're all going to
get screwed down here and
consume a lot less.
So to hedge that they're all
going to want to buy,
they're going to be desperate
to buy consumption down here.
Of course they can't all do
that, so it's got to be the
price that's more than 1 half
that discourages them from doing
that.
And they don't really need that
much to buy up here because
their dividends,
they're going to be so rich
anyway.
So the price of the Arrow
security is going to be less
than 1 half because there's so
much that they have to end up
holding and that'll encourage
them to buy.
I mean, sorry,
I said the logic backwards.
There's so much that they're
going to have to end up
consuming because the economy is
so productive.
How can you get them to plan to
consume that much up there?
It's by having a low Arrow
security price.
So even in advance they know
that they're going to end up
consuming a lot and they're
happy to do that because they're
willing to buy Arrow securities
because they're so cheap.
So how do we solve all this?
So everybody following the
problem?
It's quite a complicated
problem, but it turns out to
have a very simple answer.
Yep?
Student: So the down
state, the price of consumption
is high but the price of land is
low?
Prof: Right, so.
Well, so if you start--starting
from here the price of
consumption--
if you want to buy at this
point, consumption at this
point,
you're going to have to pay
more than 1 half to get it,
but you know that once you get
here the price of land is going
to have dropped.
So yes, I'm agreeing with you.
Student: I understand
the first part because the CAPM
price...
Prof: Right,
now why should the price of
land be lower here?
Remember, the price of land is
always in terms of the
consumption good that period.
Every period I might as well
take an apple to have a price of
1.
So you see, the land here is
producing an entire apple,
and on average going forward
it's going to be producing 1
apple.
The geometric average of all
these numbers is 1 starting at
this point.
Once you've gone down to here
production has deteriorated.
The land is only producing 1
half an apple here,
and in the future instead of
producing 12 it's going to
produce 3 apples here and only 3
quarters of an apple.
So it's crummier land down
here, so you're going to pay
less for the land.
Any other questions?
But I'm going to tell you
exactly what you'll pay for the
land.
So we're going to solve this.
So need to solve for land price
in each state,
and interest rate at each
state, and price of up Arrow
security,
and price of down Arrow
security at each state.
So how can we do all that?
Well, first of all you notice
that the Arrow securities are
always the key.
Once you solve for those you
can figure out everything else.
So we just have to solve for
these, the price of the up and
down Arrow securities in every
state.
Oh, this was me in a previous
class today.
I didn't erase it.
I figured the next guy would do
it, serves me right.
So how can we solve this?
Well, we can guess,
let's do it up here,
guess that these prices,
Arrow prices,
the same at every state.
So what do I mean by that?
I mean, here,
how many apples would you pay
to get an apple here?
I'm guessing that that's the
same amount you would pay here
to get an apple here.
And what you'd pay in apples at
this point to get an apple down
here is going to be the same as
this generation would pay to get
an apple down here.
That's a guess.
We have to verify that that's
going to work.
It seems like everything is
sort of homogeneous,
and so guess that price of land
is proportional to dividends in
that state.
Well, the whole thing is sort
of homogeneous and everything,
so if the land here is 4 times
as good as the land here,
the land here is 4 times as
good as the land here,
because the dividends are
always 4 times higher if you go
up one thing.
So this is 4 times that,
that's 4 times that.
So why not guess that the price
of land is 4 times here than it
is here, 4 times higher here
than it is here.
Sounds possible,
anyway, and of course these are
going to turn out to be correct
guesses.
So once you make these guesses
it's going to be very simple to
find the equilibrium,
and then we can verify that the
guesses are correct.
So what does this guy want to
do here?
So assume you only work when
you're young.
So what's your income?
What's anybody's income like
this young guy here?
Young at time 1,
so this is time 1 here,
time 2, time 3,
time 4, so at time 1 their
income is 3 because that's what
their wage was.
They work when they're young
and they've got three.
That's it.
They don't own the land when
they're born.
They're going to buy the land
but they don't own it now,
and so what do they want to do?
They want to consume when
they're young,
their utility,
remember?
So what's their budget set?
Their budget set is they can
consume Y, that's consuming
here, or they can consume here
or here.
So they can consume
P_up times
Z_up P_down
times Z_down.
That's what they can do with
those Arrow securities.
So what are they trying to
maximize?
They're trying to maximize 1
half log Y 1 quarter log
Z_up 1 quarter log
Z_down.
That's what they're trying to
do.
So what do we have to do?
We have to clear this market
and this market given what the
young are going to do in the
next period,
but let's see what this guy's
going to do when he's young.
Everybody is going to face a
similar, basically a scaled up
version of this problem.
So this is what the guy is
doing here.
He's got an income of 3 and
there's the price of up and down
Arrow securities.
That's going to tell him what
to consume here and what to plan
to consume up here and down
here.
Student: Do you change
your utility function?
Prof: So utility
function is the same one as
this.
I just multiplied through by 1
half, right?
So I put 1 half,
1 quarter, 1 quarter to get
that.
So I've just multiplied it all
by a constant.
So now the coefficients add up
to 1;
1 half, 1 quarter and 1 quarter.
That's his budget constraint,
but what's the budget
constraint going to be of a guy
down here?
It's exactly the same.
He's going to maximize the same
utility function and his budget
constraint,
since the prices of the Arrow
securities are the same,
the only difference is going to
be that he's only got 3 halves
here.
So they're pretty similar
problems.
So let's see what the guy at
time 1 is going to do.
That's going to imply that Y =
(Cobb-Douglas) 1 half times (his
income) 3 divided by the price
of Y which is just 1,
so 1 half of 3 over 1 which is
3 halves.
And what's he going do when
he's old?
Z_up is going to
be--well,
his Cobb-Douglas is 1 quarter,
and then his income is still 3,
and then the price is
P_up of the Arrow
security.
In the down case he's going to
have 1 quarter times 3 (that's
his income) divided by
P_down.
So to clear this market what do
we have to do?
We have to clear the market by
doing what?
Z_up,
that's this guy,
so 1 quarter (so this is the
old guy) times 3 divided by
P_up.
That's what this guy wants to
consume up here,
plus what the young are going
to do there, but we know what
the young are going to do here.
This young person is doing
exactly what this guy did,
except instead of having a
starting wealth of 3 he has a
starting wealth of 6.
So instead of consuming young 3
halves he's going to consume
young 6 halves.
So this is going to be plus 3.
He's going to consume half of
his wages just like this guy
consumed half of his wages when
he was young.
So this new young guy,
the young guys are always going
to consume in the first period
half of what their wages are.
That's what this equation tells
us.
If this is your budget set,
this is your income,
this is what your budget set is
and this is what you're
maximizing.
This is a very special
Cobb-Douglas case where you have
endowments only in one good,
so it's clear that in that good
you'll always consume the
Cobb-Douglas coefficient
fraction of it,
1 half of that, so 3 halves.
And this guy's going to consume
1 half of 6 which is 3.
So the old up here are going to
consume that number.
The young are going to consume
3, and what's the total that's
available for them to consume?
What's available?
Student: 6.
Prof: No, more.
Student: 8.
Prof: 8;
the young got 6 apples and the
land paid 2 apples in dividends,
so the total number of apples
is 8.
So that's it.
And so we can solve that and
that's going to imply that
multiplying--
so that's 5 and multiplying by
4 is 20,
so P_U,
of course I'm going to screw
this up now.
P_U is 3 over 20,
because if you put 3 over 20 in
here you get the 3s cancel and
you get 20 over 4 which is 5,
and 5 3 is 8, so it's 3 over 20.
Now meanwhile,
what are we going to have in
the up state?
In the up state...
Student: In the down
state.
Prof: Down state.
That was the up state.
In the down state the guy's
going to do 1 quarter 3 over
P_D.
What is this other guy going to
do?
The young person here is going
to consume what?
So in the downstate what are we
going to have?
The equation of the downstate
is going to be--
so this one 1 quarter 3 divided
by P_down plus what's
this guy going to consume when
he's young?
Well, his income,
his wages are 3 halves and he's
going to consume half of that so
it's 3 quarters,
right, because when you're
young you always end up
consuming half of your wages,
so 3 quarters and that has to
equal--
what's the total?
2?
2, so what does that leave us?
That leaves us 3 quarters,
that's 5 fourths,
so let's see.
So 5 fourths equals 3 quarters
over P_D,
so P_D is going to
equal 3 fifths,
right, because the 4s drop out
and you put P_D up and
the 5 down,
it's 3 fifths.
So that's it.
So now we've got--we've figured
out the prices.
So this Arrow security was 1
half.
I mean, the probabilities are 1
half, 1 half,
but the prices,
the Arrow security prices,
are going to be less than 1
half and more than 1 half.
I forgot what they were
already, 3 twentieths,
3 over 20 and 3 over 5.
Those are the Arrow prices.
By the way, you notice they
don't add up to 1.
So what's the interest rate?
So if you want to get--a
riskless bond pays 1 in each of
these two states,
so how much is that worth,
1 over (1 r) equals (You have
to buy both Arrow securities.
We've done this before.)
3 twentieths 3 fifths which
equals 15 twentieths,
which equals 3 fourths,
so therefore 1 r = 4 thirds.
So r is 33 percent.
So that's what we did.
We've got the probabilities,
3 twentieths and 3 fifths.
Just as we thought the price of
the down Arrow security is going
to be much bigger than the price
of the up Arrow security even
though objectively they have
50/50 probability,
and why is that?
Because everyone who's rational
is going to realize that they
have to plan to consume much
more up here than down here,
but they're not going to want
to do that unless the price is
much cheaper.
So that's how we got the price.
So now what's the price of land?
That's the only last thing we
have to figure out,
so the price of land.
So the price of land at time 1
equals what?
Well, what if you buy the land?
What do you get?
You get 3 twentieths,
then you get the dividend which
is 2, but then you get to sell
the land which is
P_land^(up).
And then plus if you get the
down state you get a
dividend--so the down state is
worth 3 fifths to you,
right?
And then what do you get?
What's your dividend?
1 half the price of the land
you can sell,
P_land^(down).
So that's what the price of
land is at 1.
It depends, of course,
on what you can sell the price
of land for in the future,
but we made a guess here that
the price of land is just
proportional to the price of the
dividend.
So whatever the price of land
is here when the dividend is 1
it should be twice as high here
and half as high here.
So therefore this,
instead of looking at it as the
price of land went up it's going
to be twice the price that land
was at the very beginning.
So it's just 2 times the price
of land at the very beginning
times that same price.
And this price of land at down,
the dividend is half,
so the land is sort of half as
good from here on out as it was
in the beginning,
so let's guess the price of
land is half of what it was at
the beginning.
But now you see we've just got
P_land in terms of
other stuff and so we can solve
for it.
So the price of land is going
to equal--well,
now it's complicated.
So 3 tenths 3 tenths times the
price of land 3 tenths 3 tenths
times the price of land,
and so that means the price of
land minus 6 tenths.
So 4 tenths the price of land
is going to equal 6 tenths.
So the price of land is 3
halves at the beginning.
So we figured out the price of
land here.
Price of land is 3 halves at
the very beginning.
So we've solved for the whole
equilibrium.
It took a long time,
but I'm at the end of this
story now.
So let's just review what we
did.
And so I don't think it's that
complicated a story.
The story is that you've got
land which has risky dividends.
So instead of having one
straight line of what can happen
in the future we've got this
infinitely expanding tree.
So it's very hard to imagine
solving it, but then we've built
in somewhat special assumptions.
We've got all this homogeneity
and that allows us to solve it
because it's the same problem
getting repeated over and over
again,
just like we did before.
So the price of land turns out
to be 3 halves.
So what is this guy going to do?
He's going to take his land,
his income which is 3,
eat half of it,
which was 3 halves,
that's what we said he always
does when he's young,
spend half his income on
consumption,
the rest of his income,
3 halves, he uses to buy all
the land.
Now, with the land he gets a
payoff of 2, but he gets to sell
the land now for double the
price he bought it,
namely for 3.
So 2 3 is 5 and that,
by the way, the price of up was
3 twentieths so this is 5,
right, because if I put in 3
twentieths up here that's the
Arrow price of up,
then Z_up is going to
be 5.
And so that's exactly how we
got it.
With the land he gets the
dividend of 2 plus he sells the
land for 3.
That's 5, so he does consume 5.
Z_down,
incidentally,
the price of down was 3 fifths.
So the consumption of
down--what's consumption of down
going to be?
Student: 5 fourths.
Prof: 5 fourths,
thank you.
That'll be 5 fourths,
so let's see that that's going
to work out too.
So the guy buys the land,
he gets his dividend of 1 half,
and then he sells the land for
half of this price which is 3
quarters,
and 1 half plus 3 quarters is 5
fourths,
exactly what he's supposed to
have.
So you see it works out that
everybody's doing exactly what
they're supposed to and all the
markets are clearing.
Anyhow, the point is not so
much the numbers,
the point is the following;
that sure enough,
just as we said before,
the price of Arrow securities
are going to be expensive when
things are going down and cheap
when things are going up.
The upshot of that is the
return on stocks,
like land, is going to be very
high.
You put in 3 halves and what
happens with the 3 halves?
With probability 1 half,
that's what you put in,
with probability 1 half you get
2 plus you get to sell the land
for 3, which is 5.
And with the other probability
1 half you get--the dividend is
1 half, plus you sell the land
for 3 quarters.
That's what you're eating,
5 and 5 fourths.
That's equal to 5 halves 5
fourths 5--I don't know what
this is.
What is this?
1 half 3 quarters is 5 fourths
times 1 half...
Student: 5 eighths.
Prof: It's 5 eighths
divided by 3 halves.
So this is a very high number.
So what is this?
4 times that,
that's 25 over 8 divided by 3
over 2 which is...
Student: 25 over 12.
Prof: Is what?
Prof: 25 over 12,
is that what you said?
Student: 25 over 12.
Prof: 25 over 12,
I'm just believing you now.
So that is over 200%, right?
So your return is 100%.
Whatever you put in you've more
than doubled your money in
expectation, whereas the
interest rate,
we said, was 33 and 1 third
percent.
So of course you're getting a
tremendous return by putting
your money into capital because
that's the whole point of the
theory.
It's risky.
The whole economy is going to
be rich or poor together,
so the price of capital,
on the margin it's a very risky
thing to do.
It just adds to this inequality
in your consumption.
So the price is going to be low.
You're going to get a very high
return.
That's all I wanted to do.
I just solved it out concretely
so you can see very clearly that
you get a high return in the
good state and--
you get a high return on
capital, much higher than the
riskless rate of interest.
So there we are.
We're back at the beginning now
where George Bush--we can see
that somewhere in the middle
here things are really
disastrous.
These people who are getting
Social Security,
which means they're getting a
fixed amount here and here are
doing really badly,
at least in expected return,
compared to what they would do
in the stock market.
And so what should we do about
that, and is it true that just
because stocks make a higher
return, we should privatize?
So what do you think now?
Where are we in this argument?
Has anything materially changed?
So George Bush is saying,
and many Republicans say,
that we should let people,
you know, get them invested in
stocks.
There's a higher expected
return.
So what do we think about that?
What do you think about that?
This is a real policy issue
here.
We've got this problem in
America.
Right now we've got this huge
deficit in Social Security.
The rate of return has gotten
really poor for your generation.
You're looking forward to not
making very much money,
and now we know theoretically,
confirming what we've seen in
the past,
stocks are making higher
returns than bonds,
and Social Security is paying
people a fraction of the wages
of the young.
So let me remind you of the
arguments.
So the issue has come up
because Social Security is
running out of money.
So it came up because of this
problem.
There's going to be a deficit.
If we continue to pay people at
the same rules that we've used
up until now we're not going to
be able to afford to do it much
longer,
so we're going to have to lower
what we pay the people going
forward,
lower it in some clever way
like they don't get money until
they're older.
Instead of 65 make them wait
until 70, or do something like
that to pay them less.
That's one way of balancing
things.
And because we're going to have
to make changes like that,
that's why the whole issue of
Social Security has come up,
and now deeper thinkers are
questioning the whole idea of
Social Security.
So let me just remind you that
America was ahead of everyone in
the world when we created Social
Security under Roosevelt.
Nobody had anything like it.
Then everybody in the rest of
the world gradually copied us,
and now everybody's facing the
same problem we are,
which we know why you have to
face it.
You're giving away stuff to the
people at the beginning and so
they're facing it by changing
Social Security in some crazy
way or another,
and we haven't changed anything
at all,
but obviously we have to,
and the question is how should
we change it and what's the
right thing to do.
And just to remind you,
again, of the issues,
the Democrats and Republicans
seem to be totally opposed to
each other.
The Democrats say, "Oh,
we want to continue to give
people who have done poorly in
their lives a better deal on
Social Security because we want
to redistribute.
We want to help the poor."
The Republicans,
actually some of them agree
with that,
but some of them don't agree
but anyway, even the ones who
agree that's not the most
important thing they think of in
Social Security.
Then the Democrats say,
"Social Security is so
important because we're sharing
risks across generations.
If the next generation has poor
wages so they end up down here
with bad wages,
you know, the economy takes a
turn south with bad wages,
then the old people should
suffer along with them.
And if the young do better with
high wages because things went
up then the old should also get
better Social Security
dividends,"
and that's what the current
situation promises.
It's also indexed according to
inflation, all right,
so once you retire then you're
protected against changes in
inflation.
And then another important
thing of Democrats,
you don't have an opportunity
to make a mistake.
If you invest in stocks and
stuff like that and the stock
market suddenly collapses you're
not going to lose money in
Social Security because Social
Security depends on the wage of
the next generation,
and that moves much slower than
the stock.
The Republicans,
on the other hand,
say, "This is just
terrible.
Nobody knows what their
property rights are in Social
Security.
No one actually understands how
much money they're getting when
they're old.
They just know now it's going
to be bad compared to what
they're paying in taxes,
but you don't even know what it
is, so how can that be good?
It's not transparent,
but not only that,
whatever you think it is now
it's going to turn out to be
worse because in ten years
somebody's going to say,
'Oh, the system's not balanced.
We have to delay benefits or
something to put it back into
balance,
and we're going to take away
what you thought you were going
to get.'"
So Republicans say,
"That's horrible.
Nobody knows really exactly
what it is, and they get an idea
of what it might be,
but it could always be taken
away.
Really what they want to know
is, 'What's the value of my
Social Security account,
and I want it to be mine.
I can also then tell what the
redistribution is.
If I know what I'm paying in
taxes and I know the value of
the benefits I'm getting I can
see that my taxes are much more
than my benefits.
And if I happen to be a nice
guy and think it's a good idea
to have redistribution,
fine.
But if I'm a bad,
you know, not a bad guy,
if I just don't believe in that
much redistribution I should be
aware of it and have the chance
to vote against it.'"
Also, a key thing is these
Republicans say,
"People should get equity
like returns,
not this wages of the next
generation,
those grow slowly.
Stocks might have a much higher
return on average.
People should get equity like
return, so let's put them in the
stock market."
And then Republicans think
choice is always great.
Even if people make mistakes
it's their own mistake,
so let them make mistakes.
So those are the opposite sides
of the argument.
They seem totally at odds with
each other and impossible to
reconcile.
So I want to now tell you my
plan.
So everyone's got the problem
straight.
We're running out of money and
the philosophies of the two
groups seem to be totally
opposed, so what should we do
about it?
All right, so my plan,
in five minutes because I want
to end with Black-Scholes,
my plan in five minutes is,
okay, to make a few
observations.
First of all,
yes it's true that you get a
higher return on stocks than you
get on bonds,
but you face a higher risk.
So it's not like you get it for
free.
It's a bigger risk.
So that's number one.
So no, actually,
point zero is you've still got
the problem because you gave
money to all those people in the
'40s,
and the '50s,
and the '60s,
and the '70s.
That money is gone.
We've essentially borrowed to
give them money and somebody's
got to pay back that debt.
And so there's no way around
that.
There's this huge 17 trillion
dollar debt hanging out there
that we have to pay back and you
can't get around that.
So putting the money into
equities, or wherever you put
the money there's still that
tremendous debt.
Now the question is--so you
can't just make the problem go
away by saying that equities
have a higher return.
Bonds also have a higher return
than the return people are
getting on Social Security
because the Social Security
return includes the tax that
you're paying to make up for the
original generation.
So that's the first thing.
So the next thing is maybe it's
not such a big difference,
this equities and not equities,
because notice in this model
when the stock is paying higher,
when the stock dividends are
higher,
2 instead of 1,
the price of stocks goes up.
That's a great return from the
stock market,
but the wages were also higher
here as well.
So in fact I claim that in the
long run,
and it's amazing that the
Republicans haven't noticed
this,
in the long run over 30 or 40
years it's obvious that the
stock market and wages are
correlated.
I mean, if the stock market
collapses that's disaster for
America and you can be sure the
wages are going to go down too.
If our stock market's booming
and America's incredibly
successful it's a sure thing
that in 40 years if the stock
market is just booming along
wages are going to be higher as
well.
So if you get the wages of the
generation 30 years from now in
the Democratic plan you're
actually getting equity like
returns,
but you're getting an advantage
which is that the wages move
slowly.
So although the stocks are
bouncing up and down,
so somebody who retires in the
year 2007 if he held stock and
sold it when he retired he could
get a huge pension,
where someone who retired in
2008 and sold the stock just
when he retired he would be
crushed because the stock market
lost 50 percent.
So that will never happen if
you just pay according to wages
because they're much more
stable.
But wages in the long run are
correlated with stocks in the
long run.
In the short run they just
don't fluctuate at much.
So what is my plan?
So those are just some
preliminary observations and
I'll give you the plan.
Then as I said this is
obviously controversial.
I think I've identified the
problem in a scientific way.
That is, everyone would agree
with me if they knew enough
economics,
but now my plan,
even people who do know as much
as me might disagree with me,
but this is what I would--okay
so here's the plan.
As I said, other plans just
say, "Well,
things are bad.
Let's just keep the same
system."
So there are two basic ideas.
The Democratic idea is,
"Let's just keep adjusting
at the margin.
We'll make up for it by giving
people money later.
We'll do all kinds of things
like that.
Maybe we'll raise some tax,
reduce some benefits,
balance the system."
The Republicans want to junk
the whole thing and privatize
and let people,
you know, force them to save,
but put it in the stock market
in their own account.
Now, here's my plan.
I don't have time to talk about
Bush's plan.
So here's my plan.
Number one, the fact that we
gave all this money away to
people in the '40s,
and '50s, and '60s and '70s,
why should that be the
responsibility of the workers
today?
I mean, our government decided
it was a good idea.
Roosevelt and Frances Perkins
decided we had to rescue the old
of the '40s,
and our Congresses kept that up
for the next 20 or 30 years even
though the old weren't in such
dire shape,
but they kept it up.
Maybe that was a good idea.
It's probably a very good idea,
but because we have that huge
debt why should workers be the
only people responsible for
paying back that debt?
I would start by imposing a
legacy tax on everybody,
not for Social Security,
just for the debt we
accumulated by giving it to
those old generations.
So I believe that would be
something like 1 percent.
I wrote 2 to 3 percent,
but I think it's closer to 1
percent, actually,
on all income.
If I did it on all income it
would be like 1 percent and that
fund would pay off for the
Social Security legacy.
So then if we were starting the
system afresh how should we do
it?
And some countries like Chile
decided they're going to start
afresh.
So how should we start afresh
having gotten rid of this old
debt that was hanging over our
heads?
Well, what would I do?
I would have what I call
Progressive Personal Accounts.
So I like all the Republican
ideas of knowing what you've
got, making it yours,
and making it transparent.
I think that's all an extremely
good idea, but why should it be
that that comes from putting
your money into stocks?
I mean, stocks,
this is an old fashioned
security and it's incredibly
risky.
From one year to the next it
totally changes.
I like the idea of indexing
something to wages.
So I want to create a new
security that I called Personal
Annuitized Average Wage
Security.
So what this does,
this is a security that just
pays proportional to the wage in
the whole country at the year
you retire.
So whenever you earn money on
Social Security--I'm running out
of time so I'm going to skip
over this pretty quickly.
So if you earn 1 dollar and you
pay,
let's say, 12 percent in Social
Securities taxes,
that income,
I'm going to say that's your
income,
it's your 12 percent.
You're going to be forced to
save it, and what you're forced
to do is to buy these
securities.
So it's a new kind of security
that pays proportional to the
wage.
So it might pay 1 percent of
the average wage.
So it would pay 12 cents here,
3 cents here,
and 3 quarters of a cent there.
That's the wage in the economy
and it would pay 1 percent of
that.
And how much of it would you
get to buy, as much as you could
afford to buy with your
security, with your tax
contribution.
Now, that almost replicates the
current system.
The only difference is that it
doesn't replicate the current
system, there's nothing
progressive about it yet.
So what I would do is I would
make it a progressive tax.
If you're making a hugely high
income I wouldn't give you the
whole 12 percent.
I would take part of it.
And if you're making a really
low income I would have the
government subsidize it a little
bit.
So instead of getting 12
percent of your low income you'd
get a little more than 12
percent.
If you had a high income your
12 percent tax the government
would take 1 of those 12 away
from you and you'd only have 11
percent that you got to put in
your personal account.
Now, but it has a tremendous
advantage,
this system,
which is that if you can price
the PAAWS,
if you know what the market
price of PAAWS is then you're
balancing the system,
because every time you hand
somebody money you don't make
some crazy promise that when you
get to be old I'm going to pay
you such and such dollars like
the current system is.
You're letting the guy,
or the woman,
let's say, who's working;
she is buying her own Social
Security benefits.
So the benefits have an equal
value to what she's paying for.
So you've balanced the system.
The legacy tax you got rid of
by having the tax on everybody
of 1 or 2 percent,
and the balancing the system
going forward is occurring
because you're forcing people to
buy their Social Security
benefits.
So anyway that's my,
in a nutshell,
my system.
And the last thing is how are
you going to get PAAWS priced by
the market?
Well, I'm going to get the
market to trade them,
and I think that would be a
tremendous boon to the economy
if we had these securities paid.
Why is that?
So how would I do that?
I'd force everybody to invest
only in PAAWS,
which I claim are like stocks
in the long run,
but in the short run they're
less risky,
so it's a better investment
vehicle,
but they'd have to sell exactly
10 percent of their PAAWS into
the market,
and with that 10 percent of
money they could hold stocks or
whatever else they wanted to,
and those 10 percent would all
be pooled together and traded in
the market.
And the market then would have
an idea of--a new instrument to
price what they think future
wages are going to be.
So anybody giving a pension
plan that's indexed to future
wages would know what the market
price of those things are,
so it would dramatically help
pension plans as well.
Anyway, that's my idea for
Social Security.
So I have four minutes left and
I want to end with one last
thought, one last idea,
which is Black-Scholes.
Now, we've already done
Black-Scholes in a few problem
sets.
So what is the idea of
Black-Scholes?
It's just like the idea of the
example we gave.
By the way, if you do come next
week and you want to question me
about my Social Security plan
and criticize it I'd be thrilled
to be criticized because you
can't learn anything unless
you're criticized and I think I
can defend it too.
But anyhow, this is an idea
which obviously hasn't caught on
yet because Social Security
reform stopped.
We've got worse problems to
worry about,
but if we get through this
crisis the very next thing on
Obama's agenda is going to be
reforming Social Security.
So I'm ready.
So let me just end with
Black-Scholes.
So in 1972 Black and Scholes
wrote a famous paper.
And what did they do?
They started off by saying,
this model we had,
you see, of the stock market
which follows a geometric random
walk,
it can go up by a certain
percentage or down by a certain
percentage.
We've used that with interest
rates too.
They can go up or down by a
certain percentage.
Here the stocks can go up or
down by a certain percentage.
We saw that you could solve
models like that very easily.
So Black and Scholes,
Fischer Black who is a great
economist, and Myron Scholes who
won the Nobel Prize,
but was not as mathematical as
Fischer Black.
Anyway, he started the hedge
fund Long Term Capital.
Myron Scholes was one of the
people.
They looked in 1972 at the
returns each day on the S&P
500, and they binned them up
like this.
So here are the number of times
the return was between .47
percent and some other number.
And then they compared that to
a normally distributed random
variable, and look how close to
normally distributed it is.
It's practically like that.
So this thing over here is
exactly normally distributed,
and this is the frequency graph
of what actually happened that
year,
incredibly close to normally
distributed.
If you take the cumulative
occurrence of each thing and
compare it to the normal it's
incredibly close to the normal.
So they said, "Gosh,
isn't it great,
this model of things going up
or down by a certain percentage
every year,
maybe with a drift,
that's exactly the model the
stock market seems to follow,
and maybe interest rates follow
that sort of model too,"
and that's why we've worked
with all those models.
Well, it turns out if you make
those assumptions and then you
try to solve for option prices
you can do it very quickly
through some formula,
which I'm not going to have
time to present.
It'll only take one minute,
but I'm going to skip that.
So what happened then?
So this was the second high
point of, you know,
there's the CAPM model and then
the Black-Scholes model.
You've done problems with
Black-Scholes now in the problem
set to figure out the value of a
call option.
So I'm just pointing out that
you could put it in a spread
sheet like I've done,
which will be on the web.
And you can do daily returns,
and fix the standard deviation
and stuff,
and do backward induction
incredibly quickly,
and figure out the value of the
call option,
even get a closed form formula
for it,
and then explain why call
option prices have the form that
they do.
So it was a great triumph and
it relied on things being
normally distributed.
I'm down to 30 seconds.
So what happened?
If you do the same thing
recently--so you do exactly the
same thing and bin everything up
like Fischer Black did,
not in 1972--shit,
sorry.
Not in 1972 but the last five
years, say, they only did one
year, but you do the last five.
Actually I did this a couple
years ago, so from seven years
ago to two years ago.
If the pink thing is normally
distributed and we do the same
binning that Black and Scholes
did,
look everyday at what the
return is and stick it in a bin
and just do the frequency thing,
what do you see?
You see that there are a lot
more times where in reality the
move was very small,
but there are a lot more times
in reality where the move was
very big.
So this is precisely what you
call a fat tail,
that you get smaller moves than
the normally distributed ones
but also bigger moves than the
normally distributed ones.
So you can have some big
negative moves.
And so we know we've had some
huge negative shocks.
So I'm ending now with this
thought that finance produced
remarkable theories,
remarkably precise predictions,
and for decades at a time it
seemed those were borne out in
practice.
But then looking back 50 years
later or 30 years later on these
discoveries we see that they
don't do quite as well as they
seem to be doing at first
glance.
So something's missing in the
theory, and I think the subject
is so exciting because it's so
connected to the world.
Everybody talks about finance
nowadays.
Anyone in the world is spending
half their time thinking about
finance and the theory is still
up in the air because the old
classics of the theory no longer
hold.
And so it's an exciting time to
be developing a new theory and
maybe you'll think about it in
the future.
So I'll see you,
some of you,
next week.